One of my favorite parts about our trip to Ireland
was our time that we spent at Bali Malu Cookery School.
So this school is settled on a hundred acre farm
where they have chickens, they have pigs,
they have cows and they're growing a lot of their own produce
that they're using in the school.
One of my favorite parts was seeing their acre wide glass house
where they're growing just enormous amount of food in there
which is so cool to see.
And then inside the school are world renowned chefs
teaching students from all over the world
how to make food from scratch.
So, so incredible to see.
These chefs are sourcing only the best ingredients
and just making everything slow and from scratch is so amazing.
Each student makes a three course meal every day.
They have a 12 week course
and every day they make a three course meal
and then at lunch they sit down and eat it.
So that was one of the highlights today.
We all sat down and ate an amazing lunch prepared by these chefs.
And then we ended the night at a market and we had,
we think we had the world's best fish and chips.
They were so delicious.
And then we bought a huge chunk of homemade butter from this Irish man
and his Irish Jersey cows.
Was so good. Best day.